[Music]
hello youtube chess lovers and my
friends this is gunjan here
welcome to my 21st episode of dirty
chess tricks against sicilian
now the following trick i like to show
you against dragon
which can be very effective against
below 2000 rated opponent
and specially in the blitz and the
bullet game
the tricky position arises in the
sicilian dragon
after the following opening model e4
c5 knight to f3 d6
d4 c captures d4 knight captures d4
knight to f6 knight to c3
and now the trademark dragon move g6
well here the main lines start with
bishop to e3
and i have shown the amazing napo trick
in my 18th episode with some main line
continuation
however you are going to stun your
opponent
with this very rare but very effective
knight to d5
what a move
so clearly if black has seen this
position first time
he will think that you literally blunder
the e4 bone well apart from knight
captures e4
if you open and continue with other
moves such as
knight captures d5 as well as bishop to
g7
then i have attached a sample line in
the pgn
but in this video we are mainly going to
concentrate
what happened after black except our
pawn sacrifice
with knight captures e4 which is in fact
as per the online database played in
more than 15 games
would you believe after this move
black lost the game instantly
yup you heard it right
so before i show you the whole
continuation i would like you to pause
this video and
find out how you can get a completely
upper hand
are you ready let's start the first move
is bishop to b5 jack
well obviously black can't block with
the knight
as after the simple continuation knight
capture c6
pawn capture c6 and the move bishop
capture c6
black loses the rook just within the
opening stage
so that is right out of the equation
the more natural is either the knight or
the bishop
on the d7 and that's where our fun
begins
well it doesn't matter however black
blocks
for example the most common choice is
bishop to d7 after that
white has this winning move queen to e2
[Music]
and the game is finish right there
why what's so special about this
well let's check out few alternatives
for the black
first thing first the black knight is
hanging
and if black is stupid enough to move
this knight somewhere
let's say knight to c5 then
we have this picturesque smothers made
with yup you guessed it
knight to f6 bam
so no black can't move the knight
the second option black can think about
is how about
capturing this dangerous bishop
well again that leads to the disaster
position for the black
after queen captures e4 not only we are
attacking the bishop
but if black tried to save the bishop
and goes
anywhere then we have this
again pictures checkmate with
knight to f6
apart from moving the bishop what are
the black option
i am afraid there are not much as
the only counter-attacking option f5
leads to the mate after the following
continuation
do you want to try out first yup
you can pause the video and find it by
yourself
i am showing it right now knight to f6
jack
king to f7 queen to e6 jack
king to g7 and now the final deciding
flow
knight to wedge fight check
well black king has no more space to go
so he has to take this night but after
knight to f5
once again we have delivered
the smoothest mate
last but not least the only option
which keeps black in the game is the
move
f5 supporting the knight
and if this is the best black can come
up then
the trick looks so wonderful
can you see white's next dazzling reply
absolutely right if you find the move
knight to e6
attacking the queen
if black delivered this check then this
is really useless
because we can respond with b4
attacking the queen and now if
black played the move bishop captures b5
then we have the c4
which nap the piece and the other
alternative
queen captures b5 completely fails
due to the very common and the old trick
yup you guessed it knight to c7
goodbye black sweetie
after knight to e6 one of the recent
game in the database
continue with queen to c8
which is in fact the only other
alternative
but as you can see now the juicy c7
square
is really asking for it and yep
we are going to plonk overnight with
knight to c7 jack
king to f7 and after knight captures aid
just within the 11th move of the game
white obtained the whole rook and black
position
is all over the place
so this is one of the high profile trick
against the sicilian dragon
and so far i have catch a lot of
opponent off guard
in my quick blitz games
remember once you open and play the moon
knight captures e4 the defeat
has written all over his head after the
following
sequence bishop to b5 bishop to d7
and now the winning shot queen to e2
and after this no matter however black
plays
white victory cannot be denied
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment
and i will meet you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care